the last great war ended we withdrew
from the other worlds and returned home
to the realm eternal as God
[Music]
hey everybody so ever since the end of
that first Avengers film we've gotten
questions about what's going on with the
duplicate Infinity Gauntlet that Odin
had in his vault at the beginning of the
first Thor film so I'll explain what's
going on with that how they deal with
continuity errors in the movies it's
sort of the funny explainer for why
there are two Infinity Gauntlet
but if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'm still giving you away Ragnarok
tickets too I'll explain that at the end
of the video so as with all things the
Marvel Universe has changed a lot since
the movies have started to find more and
more success and they've changed the way
that they crossed the movies over and
the way they envisioned the development
of phases like this all started with the
first Avengers film building towards
Thanos in the Infinity Gauntlet so what
you find is is because their goals were
slightly different when they started
making these films back in phase 1 there
are a couple continuity errors that pop
up so they find creative ways of
explaining him later on like in
spider-man homecoming we found out that
Peter was the little boy in Iron Man 2
that was wearing the Iron Man mask at
stark Expo so when they made Iron Man 2
that was not the case they never knew if
they would ever get the spider-man
character but somebody said that at a
press junket suggested it and Tom
Holland mentioned it Kevin Feige was
like you know what we're going with that
that little kid he was spider-man so
plot holes continuity errors end up
getting turned into Easter eggs in
future films so naturally probably one
of the biggest ones are the items in
Odin's vault primarily the Infinity
Gauntlet because if Odin had an Infinity
Gauntlet then why would anything else in
the universe bother him he would be the
most powerful being ever even if he
didn't have the odinforce the only minor
changed to the vault at the beginning of
thor ragnarok is the fact that they
brought the tesseract there at the end
of the first Avengers film
otherwise it's relatively the same so
they have an Infinity Gauntlet the
tablet of life and time which is
something that grants immortal life on
people at debut during the spider-man
comics so because it was so powerful and
the people of Earth weren't ready for
immortal life
Odin took it and kept it safe this is
orb of agamotto it just locates where
magic is being used is literally works
like an eye you can find out if there
are powerful magic users nearby and
uncover them this is the eternal flame
which you guys might remember from the
Serdar saga from Walt Simonson comics or
from Jack Kirby Ragnarok there was this
prophecy that he would use it to light
his sword Twilight in destroy Asgard and
bring about Ragnarok the movie finds a
funny way to use that I'll talk about
when I start posting more spoilery
videos this is the warlocks
eye it just allows people to cast
powerful enchantments on other people
and then obviously you know all about
the Cask of ancient winters it's a
little like the tesseract only it's not
secretly an infinity gem it's a
limitless source of mystical frost
energy so like it literally allows them
to blast frost all over everything
and as you saw during the first Thor
movie as Guardians are weak against it
it's not something that Odin could
withstand indefinitely you have the
tesseract which we know is the space gem
now that's still sitting in there and
then right up until Thor destroyed it in
the first Thor film the destroyer was
there but ever since we saw Pharaohs
wearing the Infinity Gauntlet at the end
of that first Avengers film you sort of
throw into question the logic of the
Infinity Gauntlet with all of the
infinity gems in it inside Odin's vault
during that first Thor film so during
the course of Ragnarok you just learned
that it's a fake like it's a cheap
forgery because of course the most
recent version of the gauntlet we've
seen was at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron when Thanos puts it on and that's
the proto version of the gauntlet that
he'll actually be putting the infinity
gems into as he collects them all but
they did reveal back at d23 what the new
Infinity Gauntlet is going to look like
when he's actually walking around during
the movie next year and that's just
because they want to make it look cooler
like they want the movie to be as good
as it can be so it's just a visual
retcon so when you're looking at danos
in the first Avengers film obviously he
looks way more primitive than he looks
when you see him in guardians of the
galaxy CG has gotten so much more
advanced since they did that first
guardians of the galaxy film he'll look
even cooler when he shows up during
infinity war but just to be clear
everything else in Odin's vault besides
that fake Infinity Gauntlet is totally
real and super powerful the most
powerful object in Asgard
now is the tesseract because it is an
infinity stone the odinforce technically
would be like the second most powerful
thing the eternal flame is a little bit
different the way they use it in the
movie I'll talk about that when I do my
Easter Egg video and I talk about
certain but that gets into some pretty
big spoilers so I'll wait for that for
just a little bit Kevin Feige has
explained since that first Thor movie
came out because so many questions were
levied and every single comic-con since
that happened what is the deal with that
Infinity Gauntlet basically what they
were doing is is because it was in the
early stages of Marvel Studios they
never knew if they would have the
opportunity to do the Avengers film
there were a lot of people that thought
that they would fail go into bankruptcy
and they'd never be able to do all these
cool things that they've been doing the
last couple of years so the philosophy
for the first couple of years was like
let's stuff as many cool Easter eggs
into these movies as possible without
any real idea of what they might turn
into down the road just leaving room for
error if they needed to change things so
of course everything went great they
made buckets of money they turned it
into phase 2 phase 3 building up to
infinity war so once they knew that
everything was gonna be fine they were
like yeah well you know we did a couple
cool things in the first couple movies
that didn't totally make sense because
we didn't know what was gonna happen if
we were just trying to have fun
but like I said the cool thing is is
that they can turn plot holes and
continuity errors into more fun Easter
eggs with later and logic like with the
spider-man homecoming Iron Man 2 Easter
Egg so as they continue to have a lot
more fun with the movies in phase 3 and
phase 4 and all the movies after that
just expect more of that to happen where
things that don't totally make sense in
older films based on new plot
developments just get turned into really
cool jokes or Easter eggs so there is a
funny moment during Thor Ragnarok with
this second fake Infinity Gauntlet I've
gotten so many questions about it since
the movie came out internationally so
hopefully that explains that scene in
the movie there are a couple really big
things from the old films that get
turned into jokes in the new film
especially with the Avengers film so
when you go to see it this weekend just
remember that they reuse a lot of
dialogue and objects from previous films
as jokes like he's a friend from work
talking about the stuff during the first
and second Avengers films but it gets
way deeper than that and I'll talk about
all of them when I do my Easter Egg
video this weekend so I know a lot of
you are asking about Thanos infinity
gems you know more concrete things that
are going on building to infinity war my
next video will be for the post-credits
scenes I'll post that later tonight so
just look out for that there's a new
round of that thor ragnarok ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Thor related
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from last week riff Saturn
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for my
Ragnarok review and you can click here
for that brand new last Jedi trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight